let's go to westminster where we're
joined by the justice secretary
robert buckland mr buckland um
let's start with kobe the airline pilot
union this morning is saying
that their industry is being devastated
and it's time to lift some of the travel
restrictions
perhaps a vaccine passport can you offer
them any hope
well i think the system we devised
trevor was designed to give the highest
degree of hope
consistent with the need to contain and
control
the virus i think that uh inevitably in
a situation as unprecedented
and demanding as this there are going to
have to be significant trade-offs and
it's clear that
holidays as normal or travel as normal
was never going to be the case
bearing in mind the rise of particular
variants most notably the delta variant
i think all throughout this crisis we've
tried to strike the right balance
between the natural uh need in some
cases for
international travel but also the
imperative of making sure that we do
everything we can at home to contain and
prevent
inadvertent spread of new variants of
concern
you know this is a hugely difficult
situation i think of omelettes and eggs
i'm afraid
but we are doing our very best to
maintain that balance with regular
reviews
of the regulations to allow the maximum
flexibility
but it is time to at least offer them
something there must be some
possibility of a move surely well of
course
regularly my colleagues in the
department for transport uh are working
on
uh reviewing uh the uh the mechanism and
indeed the
uh applying the tests that we apply to
uh
the the red amber green system uh and
changes are made sometimes
changes in in a direction that will help
travel sometimes regrettably changes
in the other direction that's continuing
work we're not sitting
uh we're not standing still on these
matters
and that will continue uh guided by the
evidence that we have
okay these are decisions for ministers
the telegraph this morning
claims that matt hancock will withheld
information
from the prime minister the chancellor
and from michael gove
about just how successful the
vaccination program had been
and that suggests that had the prime
minister
known about that data then perhaps
lockdown would have been lifted earlier
is there any truth in that sadly i'm
afraid that that report is wrong uh
the data that was provided the data was
provided
to the prime minister and other other
members of that cabinet committee
uh in the most up-to-date way before the
decision was made on monday
and the uh those taking part in the
meeting had all the relevant data
uh in the in the most up-to-date way
before the decision was made there's no
question of the prime minister not being
cited
on important data it was provided to him
and other members of that committee
in in the normal way as people would
expect okay well that's clear
can i just ask a personal question here
um
my daughter told me this this week that
she is going to
get married is there any possibility
that if she opt for an
open-air wedding that actually she'll be
able to have
more than 30 guests well indeed the
reforms that i announced today relate to
the flexibility within
existing approved premises to have the
wedding ceremony
out of doors and that does create
greater flexibility for premises in
order to have
more guests in a safe way having a
wedding outdoors
it will be a civil wedding it can't be a
religious or a church of england wedding
but a civil wedding or civil partnership
ceremony uh being able to take
place out of doors as opposed to inside
the premises
will indeed allow for that greater
flexibility obviously each premises will
have its own
uh guidance and its own rules but it
just allows couples that
to be to be more imaginative about the
way in which they can accommodate
friends and loved ones
to what is the most special day in their
lives great so
uh that means that our family of which
there are many hundreds
will all be able to turn up so thank you
let's go to politics now
um you went down to a huge defeat in
cheshire
and amisham not you personally but your
party some 12
000 voters moved from blue to orange
on thursday many because they think they
say that the tories
have forgotten their traditional
southern supporters in
their mad pursuit of the northern red
wall
now um is that okay with you is that a
price you're prepared to pay
well first of all i don't accept that uh
that choice you know the idea that
somehow
voters in the north or voters in the
south are an entirely different species
is is frankly patronizing and wrong
i i went out on the doors in cheshire
and amisham and listened very hard to
the concerns that were being raised
by residents about local issues hs2
development those sort of important
points being raised and clearly
the message has been conveyed very
strongly
uh in the form of that uh by-election uh
result
um but i think you know it's wrong to
say
that somehow the party has to make a
choice between people
and that you know somehow people in the
south are you know driven by
i think somebody said they were more
sophisticated i mean what what absolute
rubbish
uh you know people are people and ish
local issues on planning and development
exist all over the country uh clearly a
message was sent it's a strong
message it's one that we are uh
listening to very carefully and
considering carefully
um we want to succeed in all parts of
our country
and i can tell you certainly from my
point of view i've never taken voters
for granted
and i know that the mps i work with and
party campaigners
uh never take anything for granted as
this by-election
clearly shows uh to be clear nobody here
at sky
thinks that voters in the south are more
sophisticated voters than north
but you talked about the message that
you heard
from chesham and amisham are you going
to listen and change
the proposals on planning that would
make it easier for developers to build
and
harder for objectives to stop
development
but of course those proposals are being
developed um i think it's right
to clear up some some myths about this
you know the suggestion that somehow the
children's were going to be
bricked over and built over is a
nonsense because the children's is an
area of outstanding natural beauty in
fact
our candidate was proposing even
stronger protections and at no time
during this process have we said that we
wanted to start interfering with green
belts
or areas about outstanding natural
beauty for example
this is all about trying to deliver
housing for our children and our
grandchildren in an affordable way and i
think
every family in the country wants to see
their loved ones being able to get on
the housing ladder you know home
ownership
is an important part of who we are it's
a core tenant of what
certainly we believe as conservatives
and once it's been good to see an
encouraging rise in home ownership and
a build last year which is the highest
in about 35 years
we've got more to do and choices to make
and i don't think we can shy away
from that yeah i hear what you're saying
about what you want to do
but as you say you've got choices to
make and one choice that you have to
make
is whether you will take away the
right to have a second line of objection
to development now in the white paper
you said you would
will you stick to that or not well
as i've said the white paper is the
first stage in policy development the
detailed legislation has yet to follow
what i can say is that in those
proposals
there are plenty of opportunities for
local communities
to have their say and to make their
voices
heard and the idea that somehow local
communities are going to be disregarded
or ignored it's just
not the case it's a mischaracterization
of the proposals it's all about getting
that agreement before development even
begins you know for too often trevor
this has been a war
between objectors and developers we've
got to change the way we do planning in
this country
and i think it's right for our party to
be bold and come up with new ideas
so you're clear that that original
proposal
is not set in stone could change well
look what i'm saying is that the
principles that we've
we've set out which is our planning
system is now nearly 80 years old
and clearly in many respects is not
working well and not delivering
fairness uh to many many residents uh
you know i think all of us can speak
with experience of that
something must be done in order to
change that uh get the balance right
but also deliver the homes that our
country needs
um development this morning just how sad
are you to see john burko
leaving your party well i think
to to be to be fair to to john burke i
think he left the conservative party a
long
time ago i mean he's a private citizen
he's entitled
to make decisions about his politics and
i respect that
what i would say is that i think as a
former speaker
he's somebody who even though he's left
office
does carry a degree of authority like
his predecessors
and i think that his predecessor's uh
authority was enhanced by their refusal
to go back into party politics it
certainly didn't stop them
speaking out i mean baroness boothroyd
is very forthright in the house of lords
for example
and speaks out on things that she
believes passionately in
certainly doesn't stop them doing that i
wouldn't want to see that but
i think him joining a political party
actually
has the effect of diminishing the force
of his
voice in politics however strong he
wants it to be
let me understand that you you actually
didn't give john berko the opportunity
to go back into the house of lords and
make that sort of intervention
but are you saying that you think what
do has said today conservative party
xenophobic nationalistic do you think
he's diminishing
his office well look i i first of all i
disagree
uh totally with his characterization
he's got every right to say that he's a
private citizen and he's made
a choice but he is a former speaker of
the house of commons
and i do think that when people get
elected to that very high office
they put party politics party politics
behind them
and i actually think that uh his voice
would have been stronger
had he stayed out of party politics
being free to express his views on all
sorts of things in the
eloquent way he always does but getting
back into party politics is something
that no
previous speaker has done and i i would
uh
gently uh suggest that perhaps his voice
would have been strengthened
if he'd not made that choice uh that
he's announced overnight
let's go on to your own uh bailey
as it as it were um it's uh reported
this morning that you're considering
intervening in the colin pitchfork
case colin pitchfork who murdered two
teenagers
and uh is now thought uh to be
uh released under the parole board
uh jurisdiction um are you planning to
intervene
to stop that happening well the decision
was made by the parole board uh in early
june i have 21 days to consider
whether or not i ask them for a formal
reconsideration
i'm working my way through that that
very carefully i'm taking advice on the
matter and i'll make an announcement
within that 21-day period as soon as
possible
this week you said that you were ashamed
of the government's record
on uh rape convictions 55 thousand
thereabouts reported recorded by the
police which only
about 2 000 were prosecuted just
under 1500 convictions um that is pretty
shameful
but besides ringing your hands about it
what are you actually going to do about
it
well the rape review contains an action
plan that is designed to
first of all uh get us back to the level
of prosecutions that we saw
about five years ago and the way we're
going to do that is by
making sure that prosecution and police
are working very closely together
in order to prepare the best possible
evidence to make sure that cases are
prepared as thoroughly as possible
and that there's a real focus uh on the
the alleged perpetrators very often
victims will say
it does seem to be all about me
everybody's focusing upon me and my
private life
whilst a disclosure and the importance
of fairness clearly is at the heart of a
criminal trial process
we do need to shift that focus and
that's what these proposals
uh commit to uh and indeed with further
support that i'm providing for
with regard to independent sexual
advisers uh sexual abuse advisors
we are working our way towards a i hope
a return
uh at least to those levels and frankly
we need to go further
in order to increase confidence justice
secretary that that's
fair answer but it's what about it's
what everybody else is going to do
rather than what you are going to do
now your labor shadow has said
that if you can't get the numbers down
into a respectable place a 2016 target
you've just mentioned for example
in a year's time you should resign are
you going to take up his challenge
well first of all i think that the
nature of that challenge and the low
politics of it speaks volumes for the
complete failure by the labour party to
actually come up
with anything constructive on this most
serious of issues i mean
it's also constitutionally illiterate uh
decisions made
to investigate and prosecute are made by
the independent
police and their operational uh work and
the cps which is
independent if there was any suggestion
the prosecutions were being brought
about because of political pressure on
me
frankly
um that's all about everybody else i'm
asking you about
you is number one is a target
too low are you thinking it's the wrong
target
and what will you do will you promise to
resign if you don't
manage to make whichever target you set
look as i've said
the idea that somehow a resignation or
political
pressure should be brought to bear on
independent
prosecutorial decisions it's not only
bad politics it's actually dangerous
i'm not going to indulge in that level
of debate trevor i'm trying to talk
about
the serious issues i've rightly
acknowledged the position we're in i
don't i've never sort of hedged from it
i know if
no buts it's not the position i want to
be in but
the other agencies who are responsible
for this have now got a clear lead we've
all agreed this document
we now need to get on with with
implementing it and that's what i'm
going to
help focus on together with the
independent agencies
okay i don't want to be flippant i know
that this is a serious problem zorn but
um can i ask you this just how useless
is matt hancock
well i think he's useless at all in fact
i've known him for many years and i've
seen him step
up to the plate throughout this crisis
working tirelessly
on our behalf to make sure that the
response to covid the health service
response the health response
was as vigorous as possible it's been a
huge challenge for him a huge challenge
for all of us but to bandy around words
like that i think does
nobody er er any service at all
uh he's been most useful uh and dynamic
health secretary who enjoys our full
support
i just want to be absolutely clear about
this because i think you're treading on
dangerous ground here
because those are the prime minister's
words and
it appears to me you're disagreeing with
your boss well you know i'm not going to
get into
text messages or whatsapp messages sent
uh
between people and then disclosed in a
rather uh unfortunate way should we say
i i don't believe that that's
actually a reflection of the reality uh
i i i've been working within
a cabinet within government throughout
this crisis and
i i don't detect any uh suggestion that
somehow
uh there is anything but the fullest
confidence in what matt has been doing
and what he continues to do so
energetically robert buckland thank you
very much indeed
thank you very much trevor